und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend donald trump hat angekündigt an
der feierlichen amtseinführung seines
nachfolgers nicht teilzunehmen
er wird dort als würdenträger vermutlich
auch nicht sehr vermisst werden
in washington wird jetzt ein ganz
anderes thema debattiert denn seitdem
sich der erste rauch verzogen hat
schärft sich der blick auf die
ereignisse vom mittwoch und zwei fragen
stehen im raum
erstens kann es sein dass die schrillen
vögeln und schreihälse unter den
randalierern die in der
berichterstattung einen großen raum
einnahmen wie etwa der mann im
schwanenkostüm kann es sein dass diese
leute ablenkten von anderen gestalten
die militärisch ausgebildet und
organisiert worden
die womöglich planten im capitol geiseln
zu nehmen dafür gibt es zumindest
indizien wo führt zum beispiel dieser
mann warum hatte dieser mann so viele
plastik knebel dabei und zweitens warum
war das kapital so miserabel geschützt
und warum dauerte es dann so lange bis
james verteidigungsministerium
hilfestellung gewährte aus washington
berichtet benjamin daniel
seine beton blockaden
sicherheitsschleusen so sieht es um das
kapitol heute aus zu spät sagen viele
sorgt man für sicherheit und ordnung was
hier vorgefallen ist sei vorhersehbar
gewesen und so steht die große frage
weiter im raum wie konnte das passieren
der chef der capital police hat keine
antwort darauf und tritt zurück
wir haben versagt das kapitol zu
schützen und jetzt gilt es
herauszufinden wer dafür verantwortlich
ist
auch zahlreiche ranghohe beteiligte sind
ratlos
als der mob tobte hatte der gouverneur
von maryland in pentagon angerufen um
den verteidigungsminister um erlaubnis
zu bitten die nationalgarde zu schicken
der war aber nicht zu sprechen die lage
am und im capitol war zu diesem
zeitpunkt längst eskaliert erst
eineinhalb stunden später meldete sich
dann ein mitarbeiter rein mccarthy bei
mir und gab uns die erlaubnis die wir
brauchten da war es natürlich längst zu
spät
lange nachdem alles vorbei war
distanzierte sich der us-präsident von
den randalierern die demonstranten die
das capitol gestürmt haben haben den
kern der amerikanischen demokratie
beschmutzt ihr die ihr gewalt angewendet
habt repräsentiert nicht unser land
derweil läuft die suche nach tätern
unschuldigen
dabei tauchen auch immer wieder
aufnahmen fotos im internet auf die
nicht einfach zu verifizieren sind so
scheint es auf diesem video
beispielsweise als würde ein polizist
die randalierer durch winken in einer
längeren version derselben aufnahmen
sind allerdings weitere polizisten zu
sehen es könnte also auch gut sein dass
er seine kollegen meinte auch das zeigt
wie schwierig es ist die vorfälle
präzise aufzuarbeiten und längst geht
die diskussion weit über diese aspekte
hinaus wie wäre der tag verlaufen wenn
es nicht vorwiegend weiße
amerikanerinnen
amerikaner gewesen wären die das capitol
stürmten der bekannte politische
kommentator ben jones dazu ein telefon
interview mit cnn
das ist ein verrat das ist ein
aufschrift das ist rebellion und nichts
anderes
bei anderen viel kleineren protesten von
vorwiegend schwarzen wie zum beispiel in
portland wurden die leute nur geführt
und sie tränengas beschossen
da hieß es das ist total okay es muss ja
schließlich recht und ordnung herrschen
während die nation dabei ist die
vorfälle aufzuarbeiten rüsten sich
gewaltbereite netzwerke schon für die
amtseinführung und bejubeln die neuesten
twitter schlachtrufe ihres präsidenten
er stellte heute klar dass er schon
dafür sorgen werde dass seine anhänger
auch in der zukunft eine riesige stimme
haben werden
eine chance in washington wie wird denn
in dieser lage diese videobotschaft von
donald trump aufgenommen in der ja
immerhin einen geordneten machtwechsel
zusicherte ganz genau richtig trump
räumt das erste mal öffentlich ein dass
es ab dem 20 januar eine neue regierung
geben wird das haben wir das erste mal
so von ihm gehört aber das war es dann
auch schon ich denke das eingeständnis
einer niederlage sieht dann doch anders
aus der name joe biden beispielsweise
fällt überhaupt nicht in seiner
botschaft insgesamt wirkt die gesamte
video botschaft ja wie aus einer
geiselhaft heraus aufgenommen als hätte
man ihn gezwungen diese worte zu
verlesen und entsprechend halte ich
diese worte auch nicht wirklich für
glaubwürdig vor zwei tagen hat er seinen
fans noch zugerufen ich liebe euch und
in dieser videobotschaft nun sagte er
wolle sie hart bestrafen
ich denke was wir erlebt haben das war
der teleprompter präsident trump nicht
der wahre präsident trump donald trump
der gerne wütet und redet wie er will
er hat realisiert er steht unter druck
deshalb wollte er zu diesem zeitpunkt
diese friedfertigen worte aus senden
reine schadensbegrenzung denke ich
und so halte ich es auch für möglich
dass wir in den verbleibenden zwölf
tagen nochmals den echten kramp erleben
werden
stichwort unter druck von seiten der
demokraten gibt es ja offenbar
überlegungen ein weiteres impeachment
also einen amtsenthebungsverfahren
einzuleiten obwohl er wirklich nur noch
knapp zwei wochen zwölf tage im amt ist
ganz genau auf die demokraten machen
wirklich ernst wir hören aus dem
abgeordnetenhaus dass sie bereits am
montag ein zweites
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump einleiten könnten
der rückhalt dafür scheint groß zu sein
bei den demokraten sowieso aber auch
einige republikaner haben sich schon
offen dafür gezeigt den demokraten geht
es vor allem um eine öffentliche
abstrafung trumps jetzt sofort aber es
geht ihnen auch um die möglichkeit zu
verhindern dass trump nochmals jemals
wieder ein bundesamt wir setzen darf das
könnten sie mit einem solchen
impeachment erreichen aber genau wie
schon angesprochen die zeit läuft ihnen
davon und der republikanisch dominierte
senat würde dieses verfahren dann doch
wohl endgültig stoppen
dennoch bliebe es bei der immerhin
symbolischen geste donald trump wer der
erste präsident in der amerikanischen
geschichte gegen den zwei mal ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren unternommen
worden wäre
danke schön ist diese analyse und nach
verschenken die bilder die da am
mittwoch um die welt gingen werden
jedenfalls nachhaltig im gedächtnis
bleiben und die amtseinführung zu bams
vom kapitol auch überschatten
wie die tram anhänger ins kapitol
eindrangen hat vor allem ein britisches
reporterteam festgehalten dass die
erstürmung filmte und dann auch mit
hinein ging ins kapitol und dort die wut
der angreifer aber auch die
überförderung der keppel soll curis
dokumentiert und robert nur der
verschickten reporter von itv der da so
mitten im geschehen weiß uns aus
washington jetzt auch zugeschaltet
genannt gegebenen arbeit stellen genannt
das war eine ziemlich riskante reporter
leistung die sie da abgeliefert haben
sehr beeindruckend das als zeitzeugnis
zu sehen aber eben auch gefährlich
und merken aber eine enorme
aggressivität und sogar
kampfbereitschaft bei den leuten mit
denen sie es dort zu tun bekam etwas
anders verfolgt wir stark
neben der tribüne wo dann in ein paar
tagen joe biden vereidigt wird
und wir haben gesehen dass die dann sehr
aggressiv auf eine terrasse dinge direkt
vor dem capitol hill gar nicht gemerkt
dass es dort eine tür gab sie hätten
eintreten können und ein fenster das
öffnen konnten indem sie das fenster und
getreten haben
und dann sind sie also rein in das
gebäude und ich und kann allein sind
dann einfach hinterher gegangen und wir
haben dann festgestellt welche
politische leidenschaft dahinter stand
und wir haben auch festgestellt dass das
alles durch diese verschwörungstheorien
befund war die dem ganzen ja eine solche
große dynamik verliehen haben der
gesamten bewegung oder einige waren
sicherlich unterstützer von rom wo es ja
um die verschwörung geht dass es geheime
nächte in den staaten gibt die gegen das
korrupte establishment kämpfen
aber dann gab es auch extreme ultra
nationalisten die pause gab es dann
leute die einfach nur so spontan sich
dazu gesellt haben die dachten und
fühlten sich siegessicher
und die haben auch jubiliert die fühlten
sich im recht und haben ja auch um viele
sätze wiederholt die sie von donald
trump vorher gehört haben und dann auch
ihnen gegenüber wiederholt dass sie
sagten wir haben ja eigentlich ein recht
zu sagen und dann reicht dieses kapitel
zu stürmen
das sind genauso viele der leute haben
ganz klar ihre meinung geäußert ihrer
wut freien lauf gemacht und das ist
natürlich genau das was donald trump und
seine leute seit vier jahren ja schon
wiederholt haben sogar noch länger als
vier jahre kam ja die macht wo ist ja
erst schon mal die verschwörungstheorie
gabbro überhaupt obama geboren wurde und
jetzt verlässt er auch amerika wieder
mit einer solchen verletzung wieder das
präsidentschaftsamt mit dieser
verschwörung dass die wahl eben von ihm
gestohlen wurde und die echte gefahr ist
dass diese politische leidenschaft dann
kombiniert wird mit
verschwörungstheorien und sozialen
medienplattformen das wird schwer für
diese nation machen wieder zu heilen und
das wird eine echte herausforderung sein
für balken ab dem 20 januar
wie wird er die nation heilen und die so
große politische kluft wieder schließen
die es gibt wenn es dort diese
verschwörungstheorien gibt man könnte
hier natürlich jetzt ein riesen zaun
aufrichten mit dem die leute nicht mehr
ins kapitol könnten aber das würde
trotzdem nicht ich kluft dann schließen
die amerika durch teilt und trennt sie
sich von robert nur von meinen
politischen vom britischen fernsehsender
itv danken für das gespräch
es war eine große freude vielen dank das
gespräch mit den britischen kollegen
haben wir aufgezeichnet zu diesem ganzen
welten wahnsinn mit dem wir es zu tun
haben gehört ja auch noch eine pandemie
die uns allen das leben schwer macht und
erschreckend vielen das leben nimmt die
zahl der gemeldeten corona todesfälle
ist mit 1188 heute in deutschland auf
einen traurigen tages höchstwert
gestiegen
außerdem wurden dem robert-koch-institut
mehr als 31.000 neuinfektionen gemeldet
das kann aber auch mit späten rückläufen
wegen der feiertage zusammenhängen wie
die sich insgesamt ausgewirkt haben wird
man erst in ca einer woche absehen
können umso dringlicher wird das impfen
dazu gibt es heute immerhin die
nachricht dass sich die eu 300 millionen
zusätzliche impfstoff dosen von bayern
tech sicherte und das bayern tag bekannt
gab dass nach ersten studienergebnissen
der impfstoff auch gegen die neuen virus
varianten wirkt die in großbritannien
und südafrika entdeckt wurden jetzt
kommt es darauf an möglichst bald zu
liefern
patricia schäfer berichtet aus bayern
der heiß ersehnte impfstoff kommt mit
dem paketdienst ganz unspektakulär in
einer styropor kräfte wieder ordentlich
geschüttelt werden 120 phiolen daraus
dürfen nun statt 600 sogar 660 impfdosen
gezogen werden die doppelte menge
könnten sie hier locker für impfen und
waren auch darauf vorbereitet dann hieß
es ursprünglich möglichen 2000 impfdosen
aber gesagt dass kümmern unmöglich
schaffen und waren da ganz erleichtert
als es hieß 1000 das kann man hier in
vier tagen durchsetzen dann hieß es
plötzlich nähe sind nur 500 aber gesagt
gehen auch noch und haben dann
entsprechend eingestellt und am 26
haben wir 100 dosen bekommen und muss
die leute aus leuten die man schon
eingeladen hatten
tatsächlich ist die impfbereitschaft
hier sehr groß beim traunsteiner
bürgertelefon glühen die drähte
vor allem die über 80-jährigen anrufer
können es kaum erwarten einen impftermin
zu bekommen der hoffnungsschimmer am
horizont was die leute warum in zukunft
sein der 50 mal wieder verwandte sehen
oder kinder enkelkinder die leute sagen
dann oft wenn man sie vertröstet dass k
impfstoff da ist ja hoffentlich überlebe
ich es bis dahin an der kreisklinik
trostberg wurden vor einem jahr einige
der ersten deutschen corona patienten
behandelt viele mitarbeiter hier wurden
in den letzten tagen geimpft und sind
froh darüber
doch spürbar wird die erleichterung erst
wenn auch die meisten patienten ihre
impfungen haben wie groß ist die
herankommt und vererbt werden kann ist
eine gute im klose so wir warten darauf
dass es endlich losgeht und wir warten
darauf dass wir zügig erstmal die
älteren bevölkerungsgruppen impfen
können damit wir die last aus den
krankenhäusern nehmen können für den
fall dass endlich mehr impfstoff
geliefert wird ist man hier bestens
vorbereitet zwei ultra tief kühlschränke
stehen bereit hier könnten bis zu 70.000
bayern tech impfdosen länger gelagert
werden im aufgebauten zustand so wird
derzeit an geliefert muss der impfstoff
innerhalb von fünf tagen die vertrag
einberechnet verimpft werden
das ist dann nicht mehr der fall unter
haben ihnen die möglichkeit dann auch
termine langfristiger und stabiler
machen zu können
nur so sind massen impfungen möglich
doch im moment steht das trostberger im
zentrum meist still denn die kleinen
mengen die derzeit geliefert werden sind
innerhalb von drei tagen verimpft
besserung ist erst ende januar zu
erwarten dann stehen zwei impfstoffe in
größeren mengen zur verfügung
ich freue mich darauf dass man mir
impfen können auch die modernen stoff
selbst folglich nicht weil wir das ganze
nur komplexe macht also einem stoff
airline werde mir lieber auf der anderen
seite wie wir den zweiten als gar keiner
denn der moderne impfstoff muss anders
behandelt werden als der von bayern tag
außerdem muss die zweite dosis jeweils
vom gleichen impfstoff seien mit dem
zuerst geimpft wurde noch verbringen sie
im impfzentrum also die meiste zeit
damit zu planen und wieder um zu planen
viele informationen rund um die
impfstoffe zum beispiel auch dazu warum
bei den bayern tag im stoff jetzt aus
einer ampulle mehr dosen verabreicht
werden können finden sie online auf zdf
heute der wahl gehen in großbritannien
die korona zahlen durch die decke mit
furchtbaren folgen damit beginnen die
nachrichten heißt in london hat der
bürgermeister wegen der korona situation
eine notlage ausgerufen
das ermöglicht es hilfe aus anderen
regionen anzufordern notdienste werden
koordiniert london meldet eine 7 tage
instanz von 1000 neue infektionen pro
100.000 einwohner und bürgermeister kann
zeigte sich besorgt der
gesundheitsdienst könnte von der lage
überwältigt werden
die zahl der im krankenhaus behandelten
kobe 19 patienten in london sei allein
in der ersten januarwoche und knapp ein
drittel gestiegen
nach dem größten ausbruch des corona
virus seit monaten in china haben die
behörden ihre strikten maßnahmen gegen
eine weitere ausbreitung verschärft denn
der betroffenen provinz hebei vor den
toren der hauptstadt peking wurde außer
der provinzhauptstadt mit 11 millionen
einwohnern eine weitere sieben millionen
metropole abgeriegelt der oberste führer
irans ajatollah khamenei hat die einfuhr
amerikanischer und britischer impfstoffe
verboten
in einer im fernsehen übertragenen rede
sagte hamina er vertraue den usa und
großbritannien nicht genehmigte aber die
einfuhr von impfstoff stoffen von
anderen wie er sagte sicheren orten
die spd-nachwuchsorganisation jusos hat
eine neue bundesvorsitzende gewählt
jessica rosenthal frühere
nordrhein-westfälische juso-landeschef
in tritt die nachfolge von kevin kühnert
an der inzwischen stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender ist bei ihrer
jahresauftakt also hat die spd
bundestagsfraktion
thematische schwerpunkte für das
wahlkampfjahr gesetzt dazu zählen laut
fraktionschef mützenich neben den folgen
der kroner pandemie auch klimaschutz und
die digitalisierung
kanzlerkandidat scholz bekräftigte mit
blick auf die anstehende bundestagswahl
es geht darum zu gewinnen auf ein
endgültiges wahlprogramm wollen sich die
sozialdemokraten anfang mai festlegen
immerhin die spd hat schon mal einen
kandidaten bei der cdu hingegen bleibt
die k-frage noch spannend wobei ja
erstmal die frage zu klären wäre
wer wird nächster cdu-vorsitzender einen
eindeutigen favoriten zwischen den
dreien die ihren hut in den ring
geworfen haben gibt es bei den
cdu-anhängern laut umfragen bislang
nicht und selbst wenn das dann am 16
januar entschieden wird
ich gehe damit noch keineswegs fest ob
derjenige dann auch union
kanzlerkandidat wird
da gäbe es schließlich noch zwei weitere
aspiranten die in frage kämen
insofern weiß man im moment eigentlich
nur eins sollte cdu nach der
bundestagswahl wieder am zuge sein dann
wird die nächste kanzlerin auf jeden
fall ein mann heute gab es erneut eine
virtuelle kandidatenrunde florian hahn
hat das für uns beobachtet
sie müssen wohl sichtbar werden
sichtbare als bisher
die unterschiede zwischen den kandidaten
vielleicht deshalb kommt der erste an
diesem abend gleich zu beginn sollte man
für den erfolg der korona war map den
datenschutz reduzieren die krone ab
setzt vertrauen voraus und darum braucht
es einen effektiven und wirksamen
datenschutz damit sie funktioniert wenn
dadurch andere grundrechts
einschränkungen zurückgenommen werden
könnten ist der datenschutz keine
unantastbare institution datenschutz ist
nicht wichtiger als gesundheitsschutz
wir müssen wissen woher die infektion
kommen
das letzte kräftemessen vor dem showdown
in einem rennen in dem dieser tage noch
andere mitmischen
jens spahn der eigentlich im team von
armin laschet spielt und markus söder
der eigentlich seinen platz in bayern
sieht zweimal eigentlich
doch dazu später in der debatte heute
zeigen sich die kandidaten dann doch
meist einmütig und unterschiede eher im
stil beispiel klima märz gibt sich
grün-rot können spricht über
grundsätzliches laschet über bisherige
arbeit
wir müssen sehr viel tun wir haben einen
wirklich massives problem ohne
klimaschutz wird es dauerhaft kein
wirtschaftliches wachstum keine
industrie geben da hat die große
koalition 2017 ich habe das damals
verhandelt das kapitel energie gehabt um
zu sehen wie steigen wir aus der kohle
aus entscheiden dürfte am ende die
andere etwa welche fürsprecher die
kandidaten in der partei haben
friedrich merz hat den wirtschaftsflügel
emi t um die junge union für sich
gewinnen können
der arbeitnehmerflügel cdu unterstützt
armin laschet und gestern meldet sich
die frauen union für laschet oder
röttgen also vor allem gegen märz egal
wer gewinnt danach steht die nächste
frage an die nach der kanzlerkandidatur
und arbeitet sich das feld doch noch
umgehend sparen
er hatte sich im februar eigentlich
eingeordnet als mann hinter laschet doch
je schlechter dessen umfragewerte wurden
desto größer wurde
spahns unzufriedenheit was er erstmals
im dezember erkennen ließ sie wollen
immer noch eigentlich kanzler wäre mir
erst mal den cdu-vorsitz zu aber auch
alles was daraus folgt sonst wäre ich
2018 nicht angetreten im februar sei die
entscheidung sich einzuordnen richtig
gewesen so spahn weiter und heute
berichten bild und spiegel dass er seine
chancen auf eine kanzlerkandidatur
intern sondiert habe dass
unionspolitiker dem zdf bestätigen
sparen lässt dementieren und laschet ich
glaube seinem wort das er im team steht
und insofern mache ich mir da keine
sorgen
und schließlich ist da auch noch markus
söder umfrage favorit in der k frage der
so oder so einem kanzlerkandidaten der
union zustimmen müsste
was sich jetzt schon abzeichnet die
personaldebatte wird die union also noch
länger begleiten auch nach dem parteitag
und jetzt nochmal heinz wolf mit
wirtschaft in deutschland sind im
vergangenen jahr so wenige neue autos
zugelassen worden wie seit zehn jahren
nicht mehr
deutliche zuwächse gibt es beim anteil
der fahrzeuge mit elektro antrieben bei
der reha ja eh autos sind sozusagen zum
hoffnungsträger für die industrie
geworden seit dem sommer erfahren sie
nämlich einen regelrechten boom
die millionenschwere förderung durch
bund und hersteller zeigt wirkung
bis 2030 sollen bis zu zehn millionen
elektroautos auf die straßen kommen
könnte klappen sagt das
kraftfahrtbundesamt aber vermutlich nur
wenn autofahrer auch wirklich davon
überzeugt sind dass bis dahin genug
ladesäulen vorhanden sind reine e-autos
fristeten lange ein nischen dasein
langsam scheinen sie da herauszukommen
im vergangenen jahr wurden mehr als
dreimal so viele elektroautos zugelassen
allerdings liegt ihr anteil bei den
neuzulassungen mit 6,7 prozent immer
noch auf niedrigem niveau
für viele autohersteller war das
pandemie ja wirtschaftlich schwierig in
werken standen oft wochenlang die bänder
still autohäuser und zulassungsbehörden
waren geschlossen
besonders stark rückläufig war die
nachfrage nach benzin diesel
neuzulassungen gingen um 29 prozent
zurück macht insgesamt minus 19 prozent
also ein fünftel weniger als 2009 10
2020 war das zweit schlechteste jahr
seit der wiedervereinigung traum absätze
wie vor corinna sind so schnell nicht zu
erwarten
ja und wenn unternehmen auch nach der
pandemie stärker auf home office setzen
und weniger auf dienstreisen könnte dass
die autonachfrage zusätzlich dämpfen
ballaballa vielen dank beim
biathlon-weltcup in oberhof waren die
dsv starter heute weit entfernt von den
spitzenplätzen
bei den frauen gewann die norweger
rentiere lag auf beste deutsche war
franziska preuß auf platz 14
sieger bei den männern wurde johannes b
bester deutscher benedikt doll auf platz
besser lief es aus deutscher sicht beim
langlauf-weltcup pianos bürger wurde
sechster katharina hennig kam aufs
podest
in val di fiemme er war nur die russin
natalja reihe war schneller als die 24
jährige
der zweite platz im massenstart über 10
kilometer ist das beste weltcup ergebnis
ihrer karriere
in der gesamtwertung kletterte hennig
damit vom neunten auf den fünften platz
und zu guter letzt noch eine fußball
geschichte
in der bundesliga droht einen
traditionsverein sein
alleinstellungsmerkmal zu verlieren
tasmania berlin falls sie nicht so
fußball affin sind und der klub ihm
bislang unbekannt ist mitte der 60er
jahre stolperte die amateur truppe
tasmania berlin quasi aus versehen in
die bundesliga sie schlugen sich tapfer
stellten aber vor ende negativ rekorde
auf mit der zahl der gegentore die sie
kassierten mit der zahl der siege die
ihn nicht gelangen und mit der zahl der
zuschauer die nicht mehr ins stadion
kamen um sich das anzusehen
the biggest loser auf bundesliga der
ewige letzte wurde zum beinamen von
tasmania die diesen titel aber seit
jahrzehnten mit würde trägt nun könnte
jedoch schalke den negativ rekord der
längsten serie nicht gewonnener spiele
einstellen
carsten behrendt hatte in
berlin-neukölln nachgefragt wie die tas
mahnen dass finden würden hier in
neukölln haben sie alles was ein
traditionsverein braucht ein stadion
berliner meistertitel pokalsiege und
nationalspieler antonio rüdiger als
lokalhelden für ihre legendärste
leistung aber gab es keinen pokal
1965 66 tasmania berlin in der
bundesliga 31 spiele in folge ohne sieg
liga rekord hans günter becker war
tasmania us-kapitän heute 82 damals 27
jahre alt bei den meisten spielen geht
es uns so dass wir nicht allzu gut
ausgesehen haben der ähnlich letzte ich
hätte also nicht geglaubt dass es einen
verein geben könnte in zukunft der uns
einholen könnte oder sogar noch
überholen könnte morgen könnte schalke
04 gleich ziehen mit tasmania mit einer
berliner amateur truppe die nur zwei
wochen vor ligastart vom dfb hoch
geschubst wurde
bei der lokalen rivalen hertha bsc
skandal bedingt zwangsabsteigen musste
wir waren zum abstieg verdammt von
beginn der bundesliga an
ich habe als kapitän immer wieder
versucht die mannschaft aufzurichten ist
doch auch ein erfolg die gesamte
bundesliga vor uns her zu peitschen
tasmania us fans kämpfen für ihren
sieglos rekord humorvoll forderten sie
vorige woche am olympiastadion einen
schalke sieg gegen hertha
geholfen hat es nichts in sorge um ihren
schatz nun der hinweis dass schalkes
pechsträhne
schon in der vorigen spielzeit begonnen
hat sage dass das war ja das in einer
saison geschafft hatten und das ist für
mich schon eigentlich ein riesen
unterschied ist ob das
saisonübergreifend ist oder in einer
saison
da soll erstmal überhaupt einer
rankommen
die botschaft der ohne dass man auch
neun verliert trotzdem weitermachen kann
also und dabei auch noch spaß haben kann
heutzutage kicken tasmanien erfolgreich
in der fünften liga der verein
investierte in neuköllns fußballjugend
fernseh nochmal bundesliga ich bin schon
verrückt in bestimmten punkten also
verrückt ich finde ich über einen
testspiel gegen schalke hier in unserem
stadion sehr freuen
dass man tatsächlich sieht werden die
schlechteste mannschaft ist in die
dichtung aber bundesliga ist kein thema
für uns das letzte spiel in der
bundesliga hat tasmania übrigens auch
verloren ausgerechnet gegen den fc
schalke 04
shrek gehabt erbarmen das war es von uns
ist folgt der zweite teil der reportage
balkans teil durch europas wilden
südosten wolf christian ulrich reist von
den gipfeln albaniens bis ins donaudelta
und um 0 uhr gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update mit hanna
zimmermann m lauf auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren haben sie
das gehört - 35,8 grad in spanien
die wurden gemessen in einem speziellen
hochtal 400 kilometer nördlich von
madrid die funktioniert wie eine
badewanne für kalte luft ohne abfluss in
klaren langen nächten kann über
neuschnee die luft extrem abkühlen und
sie sammelt sich dann in diesem hochtal
wenn kein wind weht und dann gibt es
solche rekord tiefsttemperaturen die
kälte wird jetzt in den nächsten tagen
nicht so das problem in spanien seien
aber der neuschnee und zwar mit diesem
tief bartosch da können jetzt am
wochenende selbst in madrid so 20 oder
vielleicht sogar 30 cm neuschnee fallen
bei uns in mitteleuropa wird das wetter
am wochenende deutlich ruhiger das liegt
an dem hochamt das einen keil in
richtung mitteleuropa schickt heute
nacht fällt noch etwas schnee im osten
und an der ostseeküste ist auch noch
etwas regen dabei es kann wieder gedacht
seien auf den straßen bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus 1 grad
auf rügen und minus 15 grad am alpenrand
morgen pendeln die temperaturen wieder
um den gefrierpunkt und es gibt auch
noch einige schneeschauer zum beispiel
im südlichen brandenburg auch in sachsen
und in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
zwischen sylt und dem ruhrgebiet kommt
die sonne dagegen mal zum vorschein
genauso wie am oberrhein und südlich der
donau am sonntag und montag erinnert
sich an diesem wetter noch wenig am
dienstag ändert sich alles dann gehts
winterwetter der unangenehmen sorte mit
schnee und schneeregen schönen abend
noch